it is a pleasure for me to be here today
and I am a great supporter of the center
and the CAQ is very pleased to be part
of today's activities and to be a
sponsor so thank you very much for that
opportunity I I it is also my pleasure
to introduce to you the new york city
comptroller scott stringer but let me
give you a little bit of a backdrop
before we bring them up to the stage and
have IRA do the interview with him so
the center for equality is based in
Washington DC and so I spent a lot of
time at looking at the regulatory arena
and a regulatory landscape and for those
of you that aren't familiar with
Washington I'm going to go out on a limb
and say it's a little dysfunctional now
it's become very politicized and that
means that sometimes our regulators
don't get it right there either very
slow to get things done or they might be
a little misguided and so while that can
be disconcerting for those of us that
are regulated and living and working in
Washington it also creates great
opportunity it creates opportunity for
leadership for Entrepreneurship for
being proactive and we see that a lot at
the Center for auto quality where we
focus on public company auditing and the
oversight of audit committees of the
external audit function we see that in
audit quality indicators we see it in
disclosures so it's a dynamic and
exciting time and there's no one better
to talk to us about that proactivity
that entrepreneurship that dine in it
that Dinah Dinah dynamic pneus then the
comptroller he represents and manages
the pension funds of the New York City
firemen policemen teachers 700,000
strong a hundred and sixty billion
dollars but he's also known as a leader
in corporate governance and somebody
who's really
willing and and been successful at
pushing the envelope so I look very much
forward to hearing your comments and
Iowa I know you are a wonderful
interviewer so we're all in for a real
treat so please join me in welcoming
Scott stringer thank you very much thank
you thank you Scott like can I give a
word of introduction sure I want to
announce the fact that New York has a
penchant for involving public officials
who speak a lot often they don't say
anything and that's more frequently the
case luckily today we have a important
public official who speaks and says a
lot and i'm delighted Scott that you're
here we'll have fun with our questions
later well thank you that's very good I
better leave you with something
intelligent I'm really it's really a
pleasure to be here at the milstein
Center at Columbia and I want to thank
Cindy for that wonderful introduction
and two I rimmel stay outside it's an
honor to be with a true governance guru
and I am so proud to be here and to talk
about what I view as one of my most
critical responsibilities as controller
it's my job to ensure the health of this
city's 155 billion dollar pension system
but it's truly long-term shareholders of
whether 3,500 portfolio companies in the
US we don't have the ability to easily
sell shares in a company if we have
concern with its management or business
practices instead we are reliant on the
boards that we elect to ensure that
management makes prudent long-term
business decisions as a result we
actually have a board centric view of
corporate governance but just because we
don't actively buy and sell shares or
seek to micromanage companies doesn't
mean that we are passive investors in
fact some people have accused me of
being an activist
but they're wrong or maybe they're half
right I am an active fiduciary and our
funds are active owners this is how we
watch our investments over the long term
we do not rely on boards to protect our
interests we need to rely on ourselves
to hold directors accountable when they
aren't doing the job we've seen what
happens when boards fail at enron and
worldcom and during the financial
collapse in the aftermath of these
crises investors demanded that the SEC
enact a proxy access rule because we
wanted a more meaningful voice in the
election of directors but a permanent
SEC rule was never enacted today the
need for proxy access is as strong as
ever investors depend on boards to
create long-term value and we need a
tool to hold accountable those that
don't this is why last November we
launched the boardroom accountability
project an ambitious effort to enact
proxy access across the US market we
built a trillion-dollar coalition of
some of the largest institutional
investors in the world many of which
played key roles CalPERS in particular
provided invaluable support the response
from investors has been nothing short of
extraordinary when we launched the
project only six US companies had
meaningful proxy access bylaws available
to share owners with at least three
percent of shares today more than 80
companies have enacted these bylaws for
three percent share owners and by the
end of the month we are on track to
surpass a hundred companies now that's
real progress towards generating
sustainable long-term value from our
portfolio companies in just one measure
of this campaign success last July staff
economist at the SEC released a study
which found a 0.5 percent increase in
share horn about share owner value
at the 75 companies we targeted that's
on top of the 2014 cfa institute study
which found that proxy access has the
potential to increase US market
capitalization by as much as one percent
or 140 billion dollars proxy access sets
the stage for what we see is the next
chapter of corporate governance over the
past decade investors have been focused
on making boards more accountable and
more independent but that's not enough
we need to make sure we have the right
Directors in the room that means having
a stronger focus on board quality which
requires that we do more to improve
board diversity today the corporate
boards of America are still dominated by
the few and the privileged it's the same
people from the same school the same
Country Club and more often than not
they think the same old way I hate to
say it but a lot of our corporate boards
in America are pal male is the part I
hate style and they mostly look like me
wearing much better soups and today more
than fewer the nineteen percent of board
seats are held by women only nine
percent are held by african-americans
five percent are held by Latinos and yet
the research on this could never be
clearer groups that are diverse in
background and expertise make better
decisions I see it in my office and I've
seen it throughout my career and as
long-term investors we want the best
directors in the boardroom period that's
the only way that the board centric
model of governance can actually
function boards must draw from the
broadest pool of candidates to fill open
positions to find the best and the
brightest with proxy access we have the
ability to say if a board isn't
nominating diverse quality directors we
will do it ourselves
that's the line that we have to tow this
is not Carl Icahn style activism it is
an approach of an active and responsible
fiduciary and I want to thank you IRA
for the opportunity to speak with this
group about ways that we can improve
boards through active fiduciary role at
the end of the day as was mentioned in
the introduction my job is to protect
the retirement security of 700,000
people at the end of their careers
whether you're a police officer
firefighter teacher or city worker that
small pension allows you to pay the rent
maybe put food on the table gives you a
little Economic Security after a
lifetime of public service there's
nothing more important in the job of
controller than managing the retirement
security for hundreds of thousands of
people yes we are the accountants of the
city I'm the auditor in chief we market
bonds work with Mayor DeBlasio until we
don't and we do all this work what keeps
me up at night is the security of these
individuals proxy access can change the
world and we can start to open up
corporate America in a way we can't in
other areas look at the diversity of our
elected officials over time we now must
shift this to the fiduciary work of our
corporations so it's great to be here I
am nervous sitting with IRA milstein so
help me out my staff said we're not sure
you ready for this you should have
waited to your first term was complete
but sometimes you have to face the fire
so IRA I'm ready for you thank you very
much
don't worry it won't be unpleasant you
recently said that boards by the way we
all agree completely bored Sookie than
the session that we just finished before
us was all about how we do that I think
the world is this world is completely in
agreement with you then it's important
that we have the right boards and you're
in a position to help make that happen
so now let's talk about a little bit you
said that practicing access would be
helpful than getting that done and who
can disagree they'll have fewer to say
about that but you did say that you
thought it was disturbing that seats
were being given to activist investors
just to avoid a proxy fight don't you
see a role for the activist in these in
this creating good boards well it
depends who the activist is so we have a
lot of investors who were defined by
their activism when I first became
controller and we had an issue I have
nothing against the man I respect him a
great deal but Carl Icahn had a
particular agenda rather than
reinvestment Apple stock and research
development he wanted to pull money out
of Apple certainly his right to advocate
for that but we had a different view and
I said at the time that as long-term
investors we wanted to build the company
so obviously there is a active at
activists like a Carl Icahn and others
and we don't want them to hijack the
corporate board at the same time we do
have active fiduciaries and I think
we've tried to play that role with other
public pension funds which means that
being an act of fiduciary is monitoring
the corporate boards because our
investments to
and on their success and one of the
facts that I think many of you can
appreciate there is no way as controller
that we can manage our investments we
don't call these companies and say you
know we have we have a stock tip or an
investment idea we really rely on the
boards to run their companies and we
hope very much that those boards give us
the long-term investment we're seeking
so there has to be a balance between the
role of fiduciary the balance of the act
of the activist who has a particular
agenda because part of what we have to
do is recognize it for us for the people
who protect retirement security we do
not come in and out of companies we
don't try to game the system we're
actually a little more judicious and
slow in how we look at our asset
allocation and so we want to have
balance and security first and foremost
as well as the rate of return to talk on
behalf of some of the people in this
room who are hedge funds there are hedge
funds who take an active role and try to
play fiduciary not all activists are
necessarily attempt to go like I've
that's absolutely true and so we have to
be careful to delineate between
activists who are out to benefit
themselves and activists who appear to
be doing the same job you do namely
getting a better board and let me let me
just say we could not have had
successful proxy access without many of
the partners in this room and our
institutional investors so you're
absolutely right we certainly don't want
we certainly don't want to lump
everybody there's in one space and one
size doesn't fit all right so I am
certainly I certainly agree with you and
I should make that distinction I I one
of the things that is difficult to do of
course is how do you tell one from the
other it's a well you look part of part
of it is due diligence part of it is
having informed boards that's why we
think diversity is so key because
we want people to ask the right
questions we want we want to make sure
that there's different opinions on the
boards and that's why we're looking at
diversity yes there's a civil rights
component to this and I think it's
somewhat tragic that in this day and age
we do have boards that very much do not
reflect the United States in the future
of our country but getting beyond the
civil rights part of this every study by
every measure says that diversity is
probably the greatest strength in our
country right now from an economic
perspective and diverse boards I think
play a critical role in strengthening
accompany it it's almost it's all it can
to spew this any longer so you would be
there someone up as a really good
fiduciary you would be in favor of any
legitimate mechanism to produce a better
board we again we this pension fund and
are the other large investors rely on
the corporate board model because we
need strong we need strong directors
right we don't want our boards to suffer
from groupthink I think that's part of
what happened back in at the enron
worldcom day we do need better we do
need diversity because it just leads to
a better discussion and a board level if
we truly believe that diversity grows
companies and ultimately provides me
with the rate of return hitting the
benchmark I need that seven percent
actuarial target if strengthing those
companies food diverse boards helps a
little bit to help me as a share owner
and I think I have to do everything I
can as an active fiduciary my Fit
bellamy just wander off a little bit by
diversity it or so mean male and female
you mean people with different
characteristics people that you know yes
it's it's certainly more women more
people of color but
in addition through either those
individuals or others people who share
different academic experiences different
real-life experience in there in there
in there world you want to have a pool
of people that fit a particular niche
for that board and you certainly don't
want people or boards of CEOs to say oh
my god we have a male pal and still
bored find me a woman right for does
anyone know an african-american we
shouldn't be having those conversations
at the board level what we really want
with proxy access is to have boards that
understand that they have to start
providing the next generation of board
pipeline that's really what happens so
if you have a young person a young woman
who has brilliance and smarts and is a
future prospect or some some young gun
guy who's african-american is this
company providing a pipeline you know
you start at the entry level and then
you work your way up and suddenly you're
the CEO we want to make sure that
companies think like that because again
we're long-term investors so I do worry
about where we're going to be with that
22 year old a 25 year old 20 years from
now who understands the company had all
those jobs they should not be at a glass
ceiling and I think we have looked at
corporate America and held corporate
America to a different standard and as
we break the glass ceiling in government
first african-american president perhaps
the first woman president we're not
going to have a CEO president donald
trump's not going to be president in
fact anyone told told him that and
that's a good thing for America we want
to make sure that we're breaking the
glass ceiling on the corporate side now
what I think I think the point you're
making is very valid and was the subject
of the panel really preceding lunch
which was discussing what kind of people
do we want on the board
and you're embracing of diversity in its
big sense namely people who have
different views people who are expert
and so on it's hard to come up with by
the way it's got me we we can outline
what we want my next question to you was
you're in a position now with access to
begin to think about who you might want
to promote for the board as a tough job
yeah there's been I just but I the Kim
controller number of people said to me
now you understand it's going to be very
hard to find women to serve as deputy
controllers it's just hard in finance
you can have a hard time finding people
of color to serve in positions and I
have to tell you in a 90-day transition
we were able through no design no no it
was no plan to do it but seven out of
our eight deputy controllers in New York
City or women their Latino their
african-american they have great
experience some are young and all you
have to do is ask or create a clarion
call for people of all different
backgrounds to apply and people will
come as I've gone out to speak about
proxy access about board diversity to
various groups there is a clamoring
among different organizations people
have identified women and people of
varied backgrounds who are really
willing and ready to serve on boards in
corporate America they're out there we
have to identify them we have to embrace
them and we have to give them the
opportunity to be considered the second
thing and I think we should we should
really delve into this we shouldn't
think about the immediate satisfaction
of creating a diverse board but rather
establishing a pipeline that's harder to
do because you have to build mentorship
programs you have to find the best and
the brightest you have to perhaps look
in different areas than you're used to
looking but it will pay dividends
literally if we get this right
if you get a pipeline there is a an
organization and being I think that was
started a while ago I'm trying to
accumulate the names of people of
diverse backgrounds in the big sense
engineers lawyers medicine depending on
what the cut I presume that when you
talk about diversity and you look at the
company for access you're thinking about
what the company needs yes yes that's an
important element yes and you think
about that that's right and so
establishing that pipeline is a job and
it isn't well done as yet I don't think
what do you think we think is it ready
access I mean the female male thing I
know is handleable it because there are
excellent women out there who are
clearly eligible and good at this but
when it comes to the rest of it janiers
pharmacist or whatever the company needs
when you get that pipeline well I I
would my sense is that there are more
people ready willing able and qualified
to serve on boards and I just think as
we look at proxy access and one of the
reasons why I think it's been really
successful it's not like we're going to
turn corporate America on its head right
it's not like we're going to
automatically run independent directors
in fact if I can just digress our
proposal in some respects is very
mainstream in order to even run an
independent director which is no small
feat you have to have three percent
ownership in a company for three years
in our pension fund which is pretty
large when you're the fourth largest in
America we do not have holdings of more
than a half percent in any big company
so it's not like we can go in and start
running directors our proposal is really
about sending a signal that we are going
to have a role for long term in
institutional investors so that we can
do our fiduciary due diligence and I
think that's significant
as well now I think that's but i would
say for those who are talking about
access that's probably the best argument
going namely that there are people out
there like you such as you who are
interested enough to do something if
things aren't working right and i think
that's a big incentive to boards to cure
themselves and I think that's what you
have in mind well enough on access I
think we can debate that a long time
because there are a number of people as
you know who have opposed it and think
it will destroy America but it may not I
don't we'll see I am I am troubled about
the pool idea and I know that we have we
are going to it at the center begin to
think about how do we create this pool
how do we give people who are now going
to have access or even the activists
could guys in the hedge funds to how do
we help everybody find better boards and
I suppose we'll get to that in a minute
I mean what is a better board but let me
let me go to something else that you
promoted so I think your idea about
getting better Boyd's and how to do it
and embracing diversity in the big is
absolutely on target the next question I
have is you raised the issue of the fees
which are paid to financial advisors and
I think you had a little something to
say on that so possibly you can
elaborate on that of it just a little
it's been a busy two years so believe it
or not but in the New York City
retirement system when we would report
our how much value was created we never
disclosed in the new york city pension
system valued neta fees so we always
talked about the value or what was
created be on the benchmark but we never
deducted the fees so we looked at these
fees over ten years and what we found
was pretty startling
in one of our asset classes we created
2.5 billion dollars of value in 10 years
right and when you deducted the fees
something like 2.5 billion minus 2.3
billion this is for active managers and
stocks and bonds ninety-five percent now
I admit like governor Engler I come from
the government side but you got it this
is simple math you don't get to take all
the value from the pension ears and line
your pockets now what we further found
is we investigated this how could we let
this happen well the reality is we did
not know where what we were being
charged so think about going to a
vacation and at the end of the day you
stay for two nights and you get a hotel
bill for two thousand dollars and you go
whoa whoa whoa that's a lot of money
what did I pay for it and it just says
two thousand dollars well was it such a
rough night that i raided the minibar
and what you know did I make phone calls
on the hotel phone was there a mistake
in the billy wright and imagine they
couldn't provide you with any
information that's what we have in this
160 billion dollar pension fund so i
have now demanded from every investment
manager a detailed detailed report on
every fee that we spend money on I want
it delineated in plain act language so I
can measure value neta fees I'm not
against paying fees for value but I also
have to see
where the value doesn't justify the fee
and this has never happened before in
our pension system and we've got to
change this well you know looking at it
from the outside in where where have you
been everywhere has the pension fund in
this treatment they're paying the fees
all they have to do is ask what's funny
politically people say where have you
been I said well I've only been around
for two years right but you don't count
I don't well but you tell you but if I
may that's been part of the problem when
you're an elected official you don't
want to be the one telling people well
you know how we always thought we were
paying 450 million dollars a year and
fees and there's usually a big headline
you never dig deep into that then I have
to turn around and say well it wasn't
foreign 50 million now it's 700 million
or 800 million and the more we dig into
the depth of the pension system we are
basically bringing out some pretty tough
news now with that tough medicine and
tough news we are demanding more
accountability from the people we do
business with and I will tell you some
great news a first step many of you know
that unlike any other pension system in
the world the new york city pension
system has five separate boards so tom
dinapoli by contrast and state
controller he's the sole trustee tom
dinapoli wants to invest in X you know
what happens he invests the next a city
controller i have to go before five
separate boards 55 meetings a year that
talk about the same investment
ninety-six percent of the time people
will fly in to give a presentation and
it's the same presentation they're going
to give next week the week before my
chief investment officer in our trusty
spends ninety-five percent of their time
dealing with those five board meetings
i'm proud to tell you that for the first
time in the history of the new york city
pension fund in more than 100 years
we have now gone to one investment
meeting which means that we're going
from 55 meetings to six meetings we've
also raised the compensation level of
the Bureau of asset management we were
in the bottom quartile where we paid the
people to manage our money it wasn't
competitive I couldn't take a good
person from pension system and CalPERS
because I couldn't pay I demanded and
the trustees supported our increased
compensation which means now we're in
the middle quartile we're now with the
one management with with the one
investment management system we now can
begin doing more due diligence acting
quicker in a more nimble way to take
advantage of the market I'm very proud
to tell you and those of you who
understand it that the Bureau of asset
management we actually sent a team to
Boston to have a discussion with in
investment opportunities for the fund to
do direct due diligence something that
we couldn't even imagine doing a few
months ago because we're preparing for
the same meeting so reform is not just
about disclosure you have to actually
get something done and that is why the
one manager system the one investment
meeting it won't immediately create
value some of the naysayers have said
someone asked me well how much value
will that create I mean I don't know but
it'll make the system smarter will move
faster and this is the foundation we're
building that's realistic I I didn't
mean to say where were you what I meant
to say we're to religion where's the
industry where was the industry for all
these years paying fees and so on but
it's a question and I hope that other
pension funds are listening and watching
I think they are but we've now worked
with a coalition is a great young
treasurer in Rhode Island we're working
with a coalition we've petitioned or
we've sent a letter to the SEC from
treasurers and controllers around the
country asking for the SEC to give us a
guide post or help initiate regulations
or disclosure rules
so we can standardize disclosure of fees
so it's not left to individual
controllers can I do a commercial my
commercial is for crown which you may
have heard is our computer system and
our analysis which lets us get into the
the image of what's filed in Washington
and we're learning a lot about what's
that you will have available very
shortly an ability to get in and find
out what people are paying and who's
paying what which you haven't had up
until now so crown I think will provide
a very useful device view and we're all
very proud that it's in the
in-development malik photo and I think
the more noise that you as a good
controller are making the better I mean
you really get the word out that
everybody ought to be thinking about
this it's not that you don't want to pay
fees you're going to pay fees but a
payment but you want to get you want to
get your money's worth and it really is
when I saw the numbers i was astonished
myself I but whoever thought but then
again I'd like to set we can't paint
with you know a broad brush there are a
couple of sectors of investing advisors
who are earning their fees I saw the
article in The Wall Street Journal the
other day about the private equity
people they seem to be earning they keep
I don't know what your experience has
been with them I they they seem to have
been producing returns commensurate with
what they're charging you know I have no
brief for this i'm just gonna listen I
haven't spent you know a lot of time
you'll go in drilling down individually
and I think you said something that's
very obvious we are willing to pay for
fees but in layman's terms you know I'm
a die-hard New York jet fan and i would
pay anything for a quarterback to get to
the Super Bowl
you know I want my four-year-old to see
one super bowl in my lifetime so we'll
pay anything but we're tired of paying a
value right for a team that has very
little value for the salary cap and in
real life you want to get the best bang
for the buck in whatever industry you're
in I think you're absolutely right the
other unfortunately we starting to run
at a time we went too fast one of the
problems that you mentioned which you're
correcting also is the question of
paying people on your staff which had
been a big problem and you say you were
at the bottom of the page rain for good
investment Allison and now you have did
you run into political problems and
trying to compensate people you know I'm
sure I will yeah I'm sure you know at
some point you have to go take you have
to I mean as a lected official
everything I do at some point will be
interpreted by the media and the people
who vote for me and so I'm sure people
will say well why are you you know why
are you paying more compensation and
what I'm going to argue to the retire
the retirees especially in the city that
we want to attract the best of the
brightest to protect retirement security
so I look forward to to justifying this
work you can the thing I've learned
about being elected official you can do
it two ways you could put your finger in
the air and follow where the wind is
blowing or you can keep your finger down
do the right thing but you have to have
the ability to articulate what your
reform agenda was and how you measure it
and I've always felt felt it was better
to do it that way because i actually
think voters are very smart intelligent
but this is a political question when
you when you're you're not this chief
investment officer you're the elected
controller so yes we're going to have to
you know at some point a couple years
explain it I want you to know you've got
a lot of allies out thank you believe
you doing the absolutely positively
right thing and getting the best people
to work for you because get that in the
end is the best and again I'm proud and
to present you to the public and very
proud that New York has a controller
like this and very nice I think what
you're doing is is remarkable and it's a
good good indication of what other
pension funds around the country or to
be doing and for the sake of all the
retirees congratulations those are the
people you're working for and when you
talk about working in New York and not
getting criticism you're talking about
someplace I don't know I don't know it's
not so congratulate thank you all very
much thanks for listening thank you